hello Lex I'm wondering if you recall
what was the initial spark or
inspiration that drove you towards work
in AI was it when you were pretty young
or was it in more recent years so I want
to become a psychiatrist I wanted to I
thought of it as kind of engineering the
human mind by sort of manipulating it I
thought that's what I thought of
Psychiatry is by using words to sort of
explore the depths of the mind and be
able to adjust it but then I realized
that psychiatry can't actually do that
and modern psychiatry is more about sort
of bioengineering as drugs and so or
sort of I thought that the way to really
explore the engineering of the mind is
the other side is to build it sort of
and that's also when C++ really became
the cool hot thing so I learned to
program at 12 and then never look back
hundreds of thousands of lines later
just I love program I love building and
that's to me is the best way to
understand the mind is to build it
you